all right what up guys welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I give my
thoughts either when I do my makeup
drink coffee whatever I'm doing in the
morning so today I'm doing makeup I'm
getting ready for a podcast today I
actually fly back to England
I hate this flight I literally hate this
flight but I fly back to England it's a
10 hour flight and
um
oh and yeah we're actually hiring for
management right now so if any of you
are in operations
CEO like whatever
um our network is hiring so you know
um
but what I was thinking about today
I was thinking about today
actually
the women's soccer team
and I was thinking about how they keep
asking for more pay I was thinking about
how
they just you know every couple of
months we hear them whining doing some
media campaign about how they need to be
paid more and blah blah blah
and you know guys women's sports
I played most of my life for me it was
actually a really positive experience
like it kept me out of a lot of trouble
um it probably got
you know maybe a little more masculine
so that's probably a
a drawback but you know
I think it kept me out of trouble
um taught me to work hard like it just
I I was in that positive but
I have to say what I know about women's
sports is we all operate at a loss
meaning
um I did college sports and we always
spent more money than we made
and that was just what it was
um so that essentially means that the
men all take a pay cut or they take
money out of their budget so we can play
and the thing about men is men don't
really whine like men just are really
not whiners like that like they don't
you know they're if they think they got
a good thing going
they're just happy campers women on the
other hands we'll divorce billionaires
can you imagine divorcing a billionaire
a man would never divorce a billionaire
woman he just would never do it and
that's one big difference between men
and women voting is men will kind of
understand if they have a good president
or good government going women it's like
they're not even happy with the men
that they make babies with
how are they going to be happy with the
leader of the country or at least
content at least content like women
we're always looking for the next best
thing
you think that's different in politics
oh hell no so
okay
where was I going with this oh the the
women's sports and I was thinking about
this if I was a guy and every year
these ladies were just bitching at me
and saying they don't get paid enough
even though they don't even make any
money so it's like it's really just like
a pat on the back for sports
and I was thinking I'm like I would just
cut the whole thing I would just get so
pissed off and I'd be like you know what
ladies
you guys wanted to whine you weren't
happy with what you got so we're just
gonna cut all of it
good luck
and that's what if I keep seeing this
whining even though I love women's
sports
this is what I'm going to encourage them
to do because clearly no one wants to
watch it not enough of us want to do it
and unfortunately
um
we suck so it's like if we can't figure
out how to make money at it then shut
the [__] up
and if you're not gonna shut the [__] up
sorry guys uh you know I got a little
potty mouth but it's like if you're not
gonna shut up
then cut it yeah so I'm gonna call for
everybody if the women won't stop
whining you whiners I just say cut the
whole thing because I'm really sick of
hearing about it and as a female athlete
um it doesn't help us because what it
does is it makes people girls around me
whine and when girls around me wine I
just get annoyed I'm like fine cut it
so
yeah that's my two cents um the only way
that I think women's sports will make
money
um I'm gonna give them my business
advice I would make them I'd have to
this this isn't like happily I'm telling
you this but I really think the only way
they would make bunny is if they added
in social media somehow so started
managing the girls brand deals and like
made them you know
social media stars but the issue is then
you know women were dummies and we'll
just start taking off our clothes and
get naked and that's just what we do
women right
anyways guys um that's my morning coffee
thought so let me know what you guys
think like the video subscribe I'll talk
to you later